well there is new trouble this is
troubling information about an attack in
new Jared killed four American soldiers
Staff Sergeant Brian Black Staff
Sergeant Jeremiah Johnson sergeant Lee
David Johnson and Staff Sergeant Dustin
Wright died when Islamic militants
ambushed their patrol in October now an
investigation raises questions about
their mission and whether the group was
prepared for the threat David Martin is
at the Pentagon David good morning good
morning a family member of one of the
Dead who has been briefed on the
investigation told CBS News the leader
of that ambush patrol thought his men
were being sent on a mission they were
not ready for Captain Michael Peres zeny
objected when his team's mission was
changed from a patrol meeting with
village elders to a hunt for a wanted
terrorist perro zini had only recently
taken command of the team of 11 American
soldiers who had been in Nazaire for
barely a month had not done the
traditional in-person turnover with the
unit they were replacing and had not
conducted enough training within each
Aryan soldiers they were operating with
the focus of effort colonel bradley
moses the commander of Special Forces in
Nazir ordered Peruzzi need to proceed
according to a family member briefed on
the investigation the patrol had visited
a village to meet with local leaders and
was returning to its base when they were
directed to search the last-known
location of a local leader of Isis
retired General Donald bull duck is a
former commander of Special Operations
in Africa the threat was probably
watching him knew how big they were knew
what their capabilities were but Colonel
Moses considered it low risk because the
surveillance aircraft had been watching
the site for six hours and detected no
activity reaching the location in the
early morning hours / Rossini's teams
searched the site destroyed the
motorcycles and other equipment they
found then set out again to return to
base
by then the surveillance aircraft had
run low on fuel leaving the team without
anyone watching over them that's when
they were ambushed by a force estimated
to be three times their size there was
probably lack of resources
that you know contributed to the team
moving into an area that it was not
prepared for completely what had started
out as a one-day patrol turned into an
overnight mission and it appears that
gave the terrorists time to move into
position and spring their ambush Gail
boy thank you very much David very
disturbing thank you so much